wir haben jennifer rostock schon
angereist zum movie soko seid ihr gut
angekommen supergeil oder fahrverbot es
fehlt einer oder richtig zum zug wir
sind so und zwar das lustige ist den
habe ich schon kennengelernt der live in
berlin um und wollte dass ich euch hasse
also es tut mir echt leid ich bin es
nicht schuld kenne ich dieses jahr von
dem haus video
zu fall zu fall wir sind da wir haben
mal und rodet gedrehten street gig und
da kam er vorbei
die welt ist klein besonders beim
buvisoco
jetzt treten wir an mit deutschrock kann
man sagen dass die korrekte bezeichnung
oder nein falsche schublade welche
richtige schublade bitte es gibt keine
schublade für uns das wollen wir hier
mal feststellen deutschrock kriegen
immer so ein bisschen
altbacken es gut deswegen ist es halt
bei uns ist immerhin schon eine mischung
gewesen aus total verschiedenen
musikstilen wird es auch immer bleiben
also wir haben natürlich rock dabei
wären pop dabei werden elektro dabei
punk dabei auf einen neuen platte da
schreit auch mal einer mit uns mit einem
feature und ja da kommt schon einiges
zusammen und ich als journalist ich habe
ja immer meine kleine schubladen parat
trotzdem ich kann nicht mehr titel in
welche was würdet ihr sagen was ist ein
guter song
super dann muss ich jetzt also die
schublade ein guter song auf mal gut
okay aber das ist ja entscheidend beim
buvisoco das ist ein guter song ist seit
er dabei eurem ich kann nicht mehr davon
überzeugt dass das ein song ist der es
ganz nach vorne bringen kann ja
würde ich sagen ja was hatte ich nur
sagen gut versorgen sagt der menschheit
gefallen müsste wenn die menschheit den
man guckt er was ist die konkurrenz was
haben die anderen für titel ist nach
einem gesetz aus was ist eure
einschätzung im moment sind schon einige
gute songs bayer ist das ja das heißt
wir uns ein bisschen raus halten weil
wir viele davon auch persönlich kennen
über die ganzen jahre und weil man das
ganze immer so ein bisschen arbeit und
privat so ein bisschen trennen muss und
deswegen wünsche mir natürlich ein das
beste und uns auch das habe ich schon
gehört man schlägt sich beim buvisoco
nachher nicht die köpfe ein nein das
wird man nicht man feiert zusammen und
trinkt verstehen dass zusammen und freut
sich dass man sich trifft das war es
einfach trotzdem habt ihr so eine
einschätzung wo er ungefähr landen
werdet hat man da so ein gefühl
unter den ersten 16 würde sagen ja
würde ich auch mit wetten dass
ist das spannende bei dem bei den
bundesvision dass man nie weiß wo man
also wer am ende wo landet weil es also
ganz oft sind halt die
die ganz unbekannten neuen bands
irgendwie weit vorne und die besten
bekannten bands weiter hinten aber
manchmal auch andersrum das ist halt
schwer das einzuschätzen fällt wie die
leute sich dann scheiden gut wir wollen
was dafür tun bei pixum damit ihr ganz
weit vorne landet und haben einen
youtube paten gefunden und zwar aus
mecklenburg vorpommern baumann es ist
niemand gering wir haben's wieder
festgesetzt mecklenburg vorpommern ist
echt schwierig auszusprechen meck pomm
aus meck pom pom
moin moin ich bin früh geschockt ich bin
der youtube party für jennifer rostock
beim bundesvision song contest
stellvertretend für das bundesland
mecklenburg-vorpommern hat ja eigentlich
will ich das ganze schöner strand hier
in rostock aufnehmen leider ist das
bisschen ins wasser gefallen weil es
draußen regnet dem man sprechen muss ich
jetzt in meiner bude das kleine video
hier aufnehmen ungehalten ich wünsche
dir viel glück beim bundesvision song
contest ist natürlich jetzt glücklich
glückliche zufälle sag ich mal dass ich
der partei geworden bin ich kenne zwar
keine sau aber ich bin anhänger deine
musik die man sprechen bin ich froh und
bin ich auch sehr stolz dass sein zu
dürfen ich wünsche dir viel viel glück
wird langsam mal zeit dass wir das ding
im hohen norden hier holen und an allen
zuschauern ein draußen die vielleicht
jennifer rostock unser bundesland
unterstützen möchten ruf fleißig an wie
gesagt das wird zeit dass das ding hier
in ordnung kommt und wir ich und vor
allem die genfer würde sich bestimmt
auch sehr darüber freuen ja wie gesagt
viel glück viel erfolg wir stehen hinter
dir
hallo lieber
hier sind seine jennifer rostock wir
bedanken uns sehr bei dir dass du uns so
obst und vielleicht rufen die anderen
die das jetzt sehen auch für uns an das
wäre sehr schön denn wir wollen ja auch
vorankommen und so und ja vielleicht
wurdet ihr uns ja nach oben das wäre auf
jeden fall ganz toll danke schön für sie